attention ce n'est pas un film pour
enfants pour cinq hommes sans connaître
que c'est pas cher
j'aurais presque aimé en avoir une pour
que telle à suspense est pour le oui
vous êtes des deux flics les plus
décorés du service qu'est ce que vous
emportez et un braquage qui a mal tourné
pour mon nom c'était pas un braquage
c'est un honneur bien actuel de fret
dans la nature pas coincer les salopards
qui ont commis ces meurtres
bordel tu es vraiment le meilleur
fléchage allez vous vous faire virer
parce que moi [ __ ] j'suis du fbi a
ouais ça veut dire quoi foutu bt idiot
car si sa part en prie je pars brute
c'est sûr que ça va gens les déchirures
mon email
c'est la bonne ce n'est du genre de
trucs
sd
[Musique]
q
le fils est là il s'occupe d'une cliente
parce que c'est ce que je crois